how do you move through that is that
where the forgiveness comes in how do
you feel it and then move through and
leave it behind or accept it that's a
really good question about moving the
energy and that's where the head
approach doesn't work and I I've got a
credit Colin tipping for this because he
came up with a step-by-step approach and
I learned so much from him know that
there's when we think about our problems
they don't tend to change same thing why
when we think a lot of affirmations a
lot of things don't happen when you
bring our heart into it and we move the
energy through feeling emotion we all
probably heard this energy in motion
that's when things start to change so I
learned from Colin and I became a
certified radical forgiveness coach I
went through his whole program being the
type A that I am I have to not just read
the book I've got to do it that there's
many ways to move emotion there's
physical ways like you know beating on a
pillow or screaming there's more
artistic ways drawing pictures there is
standing in front of a mirror and
talking and allowing your voice to
emerge from your throat instead of stay
stuck in your head and the energy never
moves from the head down to the heart so
that we can integrate it in the body in
a new way so we talked about a number of
those things in the film and it's really
the key step you know all of us
intellects we can think our selves to
paralysis but when it's when we move it
through the emotions and involve the
physical body that real change happens
you